les yvelines sont le département qui
compte le moins de femmes mères dans la
région sonia breux au maire de saint cyr
l'école et à néry le pallec maire de
cheuvreux sont des exceptions
elles font partie de l'association elie
lancé ce matin dans le but de promouvoir
les femmes dans les yvelines qui
désirent s'investir pour le territoire
où vraiment ce qu'on voudrait faire
partager c'est notre expérience de femme
et lui faire profiter des femmes qui
souhaiteraient s'engager qui ont des
hésitations des questions des
interrogations leur montrer que c'est
possible je reste persuadé que le femmes
et un homme sont complémentaires
la housse je me pose question c'est sur
le le fait de devoir le l'imposer pour
que ça devienne effectif face à ce
manque de femmes dans les effectifs des
exécutifs locaux comme à l'échelle
nationale la sénatrice martin décidera
qu'a lancé elie l'association de
promotion des femmes en politique dans
les yvelines
c'est tout simplement de permettre aux
femmes dose est d'aller plus loin dans
leurs ambitions parce que les femmes ont
également des ambitions et l'y
accompagnera également les élus dans
leur mandat il proposera à ses adhérents
des rencontres et des formations autour
des mandats politiques
on est toujours aux liens parce que
l'idée c'est de créer du réseau l'idée
c'est de créer du lien
cette association est également ouverte
aux hommes interpelle la secrétaire de
la délégation aux droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les femmes
messieurs nous sommes à vos côtés et
nous avons montant de légitimité que
vous a aussi un moment donné nous saisir
de cet espace public
la cotisation à l'association elie et
d'un montant de 25 euros